Pearson as we await those official
election totals with just about a week
from when the state supreme court
actually has to certify the vote we
wanted some context on what we just saw
happen over the past week 8 News no
political expert in review journal
politics editor Steve Sebelius joining
us live from Henderson to talk about
just how we got here hi Steve my first
question Senator Cortez Master winning
re-election with just those few thousand
votes can you tell us about how
important unions were in this race
particularly how culinary played a role
in her victory
yeah absolutely David it wasn't a
coincidence that Catherine Cortez masto
held her victory speech at a carpenter's
union hall surrounded by members of the
Carpenters Union Teamsters uh sciu and
of course the culinary uh they were
critical in her Victory especially the
culinary it has a political machine that
was well funded and they turned out uh
people to knock on more than one million
doors which by the way is a record so uh
so they have uh they have really played
a big role in her race and I think she
acknowledged that on Sunday
uh quickly before I ask you about the
state legislature sticking on this topic
about Senator Cortez masto this is a
really small margin of Victory here did
you expect this or did you expect we
would have seen a senator-elect laxal
well David I'm I'm not going to lie I
did expect a close margin but I did not
expect a margin this small this is
probably the smallest margin of victory
in a Statewide race in Nevada that I
have seen in at least the last 20 years
so I did not see that coming I Taiwan up
more people voted for none of these
candidates as we have in Nevada than
actually the margin between them quickly
here turning to the legislature it
appears Democrats will have that super
majority in the assembly and they'll
also likely be in control of the Senate
which they have been for several Cycles
now so what does this mean for both
Democrats then of course working with a
republican governor-elect will they be
able to get anything done
well whether they'll be able to get
anything done I think is yet to be seen
But the stage is set for that there is
there's really no choice uh if they want
to cooperate uh but to work together to
reach across the aisle uh otherwise
we're looking at gridlock we're looking
at Democratic bills vetoed by a
republican Governor they don't have
enough votes in the Senate to override a
gubernatorial veto so that suggests to
me that they will have to work together
to get things done will will remains to
be seen though whether or not that's
going to happen starting with the
governor's State of the State speech and
when the legislature kicks off in
February all right Steve Sebelius thank
you so much we'll see you back here in
just a little bit now nearly two days
now since Cortez masto declared Victor
we haven't heard anything from her
opponent Republican Adam laxalt also
take a look at this super close race
this is the district F race for Clark
County Commission 84 votes right now
separating incumbent Justin Jones from
his Challenger Drew Johnson so this is
why every vote counts to find all of our
election coverage our local coverage you
can use your cell phone camera to scan
this QR code right there on your screen
it'll take over to educnow.com if you
missed the code don't worry we will have
it again in just about 15 minutes